cameron mike congratulations it is now
down to the two of you to decide who's
gonna go home with the title of forge
and fire champion and a check for ten
thousand dollars now this final round of
competition we're gonna be sending you
guys back to your home forges to build
not one but two iconic multi-tools and
weapons from russia that weapon is
the spence that shovel
originating in the 19th century these
all-purpose shovels were adapted for use
by the russian special forces the spez
nets these versatile shovels were used
as entrenching tools ores for rafting
and even as cookware the soviet military
units eventually trained to use the
spesnat shovel as a weapon the short
handles made for quick moves in close
quarter combats these shovels feature
deadly sharp edges that can be used for
anything from chopping wood to slashing
flesh or even thrown at a target this
utilitarian tool can be seen wielded in
season three of history channel's hit
survival series alone
you guys will have four days to work on
your spetsnaz shovels so good luck we'll
see you in four days
good luck
my name is cameron lafrance i am 20
years old from one robbins georgia i got
into metal works thanks to my father
that's really what sparked no pun
intended my drive for working with metal
and fire i have a lot of steel to move
and a very thin blade to forge out so
hopefully all goes well
i start off with these two pieces of
leaf spring just to see if i can get it
forged down to parameters
and then i noticed a piece of w1 that i
had laying around
it's two inch round stock so i know for
a fact that it's enough material for the
job i need it to do i'm going to keep
stretching it up and then working on the
width
i got to still flatten out one of my
billets that's hot i'm getting a handle
and blade junction merged up and then
went
i'm having to make sure that they're
both exactly the same but still very
confident i can do that looks pretty
badass if i don't say so myself
i feel like i've gotten to a place now
to where my blades are ready for the
heat treat here we go
sound i want to hear end of day three i
am very happy to finally have all these
shovel heads forged out hardened can't
wait for the fourth day if he's fit and
finished up and out of here
i've had a lot of good luck in my past
with one special girl so i can go ahead
and put my girlfriend's name and russian
on the handle just as a hopeful good
luck charm and if it doesn't work then i
know who to blame
my name is mike powell i'm from hastings
florida i make blades as often as i can
usually a couple hours in the morning
before work and then as much time as my
wife left me on the weekend she
sacrifices a lot of part one-on-one time
for me to be in my shop making blades if
i win the 10k i'm gonna get my wife
something nice that we can enjoy
together
i'm gonna forge out these shovels and
see if i can win this
i got it about drawn out to length i
haven't quite got it as wide as i want
i'm not sure i have enough material i'll
go cut me another piece of steel for the
second one drop it in the forge
that ought to do it about three blows in
the whole end of the billet just
explodes wow
what the
heck
never seen a piece of steel do that now
i i've got one piece left this sucks
no way
this is my third attempt do-over i take
my time i keep my steel to the right
temperature that didn't explode on me
this time so it worked out
never built anything like this before
never even thought about building
anything like this before
but honestly
i loved it
it was a challenge it was a learning
experience it made me a better smith so
i learned i gained a lot of experience
and overall it was very exciting and i'm
happy with it i'd say that's a matching
set
leadsmiths welcome to the kill test
can you dig it
well i certainly can your spats dance
shovels look ready to go but what kind
of lethal damage can they do to find
that out i'm going to take your shovels
and deliver some lethal blows to this
ballistics dummy cameron you're up first
you ready for this oh yeah all right
let's do this
all right cameron let's talk about your
spencer shovels here the weight is right
but
there is a little bit issue with your
handles
they're too smooth a couple of times it
really felt like it wanted to slip out
they deliver nice cuts
thrusts are very effective and overall
sir
it will kill yes
all right mike your turn so you ready
i'm ready
[Music]
all right mike talk about your
shovels here these are razor sharp
your handle construction the one thing i
didn't care for was it's round when it's
round it can go different ways and i
have to constantly make adjustments but
because of the ribbing that you have
there i was able to hold on to it quite
well overall sir your shovels
will kill
awesome
all right gentlemen you know what time
it is it's time for the strength test
what we're calling our throw and chop
what i'm going to be doing is throwing
your shovels into our targets and then
chopping on our fence here what this is
about is not what your shovels do to
these targets but what these targets can
do to your shovels cameron first you
ready yeah let's do this
all right cameron for throwing the
smooth handle is great that's not a plus
for chopping though when i'm chopping
i'm constantly kind of pulling it back
into my hand because it wants to slide
forward
this
right here this
thin spot
where you've got that hammer it took a
roll right there they threw well
good job thank you very much
all right mike you're up you ready yeah
i'm ready okay
[Music]
okay so right off the bat the finished
work is really nice your sockets are
really beautiful
they threw great they certainly chopped
fine i don't see any issues with the
edge of your blade at all these are
definitely well-made tools good job
thank you
all right bladesmiths this is the
sharpest test the sandman slice
now unlike the strength this is all
about what your weapons do to the
sandman
cameron europe first you ready for this
let's do this let's do this
[Music]
all right cameron no issues with
slashing and chopping on the sandman sir
your weapons
you'll cut
all right mike your turns are you ready
i'm ready
[Music]
all right mike
your edges are sharp every cut was deep
and sliced nicely overall sir it will
cut thank you
well gentlemen you guys should both be
very proud of yourselves we put your
spetsnaz shovels through very hard test
as you know there can only be one
champion of fortune fire
today's champion is
mike congratulations you are the fortune
fire champion cameron unfortunately that
means you didn't win today and dave's
going to tell you why cameron what this
came down to was really two things we
were handled being as slippery as it was
and the damage you took in the strength
test for those reasons we're letting you
go all right
cameron you definitely have what it
takes to fight in the forge you made it
from four down to two it was a close
call but your time in the forge has
ended i'm gonna have to ask you to
please step off the fourth floor thank
you
take care cam
i wanted to win it really badly to prove
myself that i can really go up to the
standards as what other abs master
smiths are able to do
this experience it's really amazing and
i couldn't have asked for more
mike congratulations that means you are
today's fortune fire champion and you'll
be getting a check for ten thousand
dollars so congratulations thank you
i'm feeling amazing like on top of the
world amazing mike i was really
impressed on the finish you got on those
it's really nice clean from top to
bottom well done thank you i build
knives for a hobby from this point on
though i really want to concentrate on
doing real high-end work and just
improve my skills
you